manifestation aujourd'hui du personnel
des industries électrique et gazière ils
sont appelés à se rassembler à midi
place de la nation à paris
parmi les revendications la création
d'un service public de l'énergie et
certains dénoncent le projet hercule le
projet de réforme chez edf on va
retrouver sans attendre notre reporter
estelle farges place de la nation
justement estelle bonjour alors quel est
le mot d'ordre de cette manifestation
selon la cgt 1 c'est assurer l'avenir du
service public de l'énergie c'est bien
cela exactement olivier a car il
considère que le moment est fatidique et
stratégique c'est en tout cas est ce qu
a annoncé la cgt fn m e qui organise
cette manifestation alors au centre des
crispations deux projets de
restructuration celui d' angie et puis
celui d'edf le dénouement de ce dernier
est annoncé comme imminent initialement
baptisé projet hercules pour être
renommé grant edf cette restructuration
complète du groupe vise à le diviser en
trois sociétés à distingue objectif
permettre au groupe d'assurer sa
transition dans les énergies
renouvelables tout en engageant de
lourds investissements dans le nucléaire
alors il faut dire que le groupe est
endetté cette restructuration vise aussi
à remonter en les finances d'edf mais le
projet traîne et les différentes parties
elles peinent à se mettre d'accord les
syndicats de leur côté cris au purement
et simplement au démantèlement du groupe
avec cette manifestation les
organisateurs espèrent donc peser sur le
choix des manuels macron qui devrait
sceller le sort de zdf d'ici à la fin du
mois et du côté du cortège estelle
eh bien vous l'avez dit olivier il
s'élancera midi depuis la place de la
nation direction république
un cortège auquel devraient se joindre
philippe martinez le secrétaire général
de la cgt mais aussi différentes
fédérations de la cgt comme la cgt ce
cheminot ou encore la cgt spectacle
merci beaucoup estelle estelle farges en
direct de la place de la nation à paris